ازمه الغذاء تعوم و تغرق وتعود للوجه
اتفاق اشبه بهدنه هشه اوقف ثم استانف ما
يدقون رؤوس الخطر ويطرح تساؤلات المشروعه
عن البدائل الخيار الاول هو نقل الحبوب
الى موانئ بحر البلطيق عبر القطار الميزه
هنا هي توفر شبكه سكك الحديد بالمواصفات
الروسيه لكن ثم عائقا مقابل الميزه فابلا
روسيا التي تطالب برفع العقوبات عنها
مقابل حق عبودي اراضيها فرنسا التي وقعت
قبل تعليقي الاتفاق تفاهما مع رومانيا
لزياده صادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى
الدول الناميه تريد اتجنب ما وصفته
تطرحوا مبادره لنقل الحبوب عبر طريقا بريا
للحبوب تنقل عبر الشاحنات من بناء الى
الحدود الهولنديه
والرومانيه
وهناك عائقا اخر اللوجستيا هذه المره 23
الشحنات كبرى تعادل وعربه دقيقه قارن واحد
الى تلزموا ثلاثه الاف شاحنه لملئ سفينه
حبوب ويعني تكلفه في النقل هذه التكلفه قد
تجعل القمح الاوكراني بدون مشترين ازمه
الاقتصاد اضرب العالم كله
خيارا اخر استخدمته كيف قبل اتفاق الحبوب
قد تحاول احياءه طريقنا بطولي
423 كم عبرام دوفا
في رومانيا ولكن الطريق البريه باتت
مزدحمه جدا ماذا يعني ذلك
المسافه في 16 ساعه الان في كم ليصدع ولا
الضعفين
اسبوعا كامل
وبينما تبحث عن حل انفعال خيار في الافق
المبادره الاوروبيه وباختصار ينقل القمح
عبر القطار حتى ميناء جلاتي الروماني
الواقع على نهر الدانوب والميناء يحتاج
فقط لبناء سكه الحديديه واحده بالخصائص
الروسيه وطولها خمسه كيلومترات للربط
وجلاته
بامكانه استقبال كل انواع السفن وبذلك
ستبلغ الشحنات حبوب الاوكرانيه عبر
الدانوب الى المانيا ومرورا بالنمسا وايضا
كرواتيا
اذا اتفاقوا الحبوب المبرم برعايه امميه
شهر يوليو الماضي ورغم استئنافه ولدها
الشمس وبمرور الاسابيع وجدت موسكو سببا
لايقافه وقدمت لها اوكرانيا الحجه
والذريعه على طبق من ذهب
طائرات مسيره على اسطول البحر الاسود في
سبسبول تجاوز للحدود بالنسبه لروسيا
متحهما كياف ومن وراءها لندن بالامر
استانفتهم واثقه لكن
الشروط الجديده
للعمل بصفقه الحبوب مع اوكرانيا بعد جهود
الامميه وتركيا لكن الاهم انها عادت
بضمانات خطيه من اوكرانيا موسكو اشترطت
اولا عدم استخدام الممر الامني المخصص
لمرور السفن المحمله بالقمح بشنها هجمات
ارهابيه على الاراضي الروسيه ثانيا تصدير
الحبوب الى الدول الاكثر احتياجا في
افريقيا واسيا حيث ترى موسكو ان الحبوب لا
تصل لهذه الدول بل للدول الاوروبيه وهي
انتقائيه متحيزه كما تقول موسكو حتى الان
تعتبر هذه الضمانات المكتوبه التي قدمتها
اوكرانيا كافيه لاستئناف هذه الصفقه من
جديد لكن هل تكون كافيه في المستقبل
اذا كما ذكرت مراسلتنا اتهمت روسيا الغرب
بانتقائيه في التوزيع لتطرح خطه لتعويض
القمح الاوكراني خطب مجانا
هذه البلدان وهكذا نالت استحسان الامم
المتحده التي لا طالت وجهه اليها سهام
الانتقادات لكن الاوروبيين لا يؤمنون ولا
يؤمنون بكرم روسيا وخصوصا في زمن الحروب
اتهموها بالتسلح لكن بقمحي اوكرانيا
والغايه السياسيه بالطبع